[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
let me bring in peter king nbcsports.com
and
uh football morning in america pete
thanks for joining us happy new year
let's start with the eagles
last night any issues with uh doug
peterson
yes i thought it was not a good thing
for
i i mean what's the right term uh the
honor of the game
the honor code that coaches have to have
um
and i'm not saying that uh that
jalen hurts was playing great i'm saying
that nate
sutfield had not stepped on a football
field
for 105 weeks and
you put them in the game with whatever
10 12 minutes to go
you're gonna have three more possessions
in this game probably
you're down by three points um and again
i don't think he did this with the with
the thought of
the sixth pick or the ninth pick in mind
i think he did it because he
legitimately wanted to see nate sutfield
this was not him you know
playing with the integrity of
his draft choice let's say or playing
with his draft choice
it was i think he legitimately wanted to
see him
i don't think that it's the right time
or the right place to do it
and i think he you should do everything
you can to win a game
uh particularly when a division title is
on the line and doug peterson did not do
that
but it's two different messages that
you're saying hey
sudfeld you you know that he has the
right to do it he wants to see what they
have
this isn't an important game for the
eagles it's an important
if this if there was no playoff birth
attached to this
would anybody care that he no no
but there was a playoff berth attached
to it there was two teams
sitting at the end of your edge of their
seat
and look i would just ask this question
and again logan ryan i talked to him
about midnight last night of the giants
and he said
listen we really we basically didn't
deserve it
you know i'm not mad at the eagles now
you know
off the record is he mad at the eagles i
don't know but
uh you know he told me i'm not mad at
the eagles we
we didn't put ourselves in in good
enough position
by winning six games however
i am just saying if doug peterson were
the other team
right there if it was washington playing
the giants
and washington pulled alex smith for
john doe
you know to me look somebody said it on
twitter last night you know the time to
look at nate sutfield
is is either last august or this august
not in the middle of a game with the
pennant on the line
yeah i i agree when i'm watching i'm
going if you don't know what you have
with nate sudfeld
then that's on you like i'm not he
doesn't have much with nate sutfield
based on what we saw last night
yeah you know look but now he knows
he does know what he has in his son i'd
be shocked if he didn't if he really
didn't know what he had but
i disagreed with what he did where will
carson wentz be next year
um i think a lot of
that is going to depend on something
that is totally out of the philadelphia
eagles hands unless
the eagles say right now absolutely
we're not getting rid of you
we're going to go to marriage counseling
uh
and and absolutely that but i think this
depends quite a bit on
whether frank wright uh has fallen in
love with phillip rivers enough
to say that uh entering 2021
they want to go another one year 25
million with
with phillip rivers now if the cap does
go down some they may have to say to
philip rivers
you got to take a 5 million haircut or
uh we're gonna move on and and so
the most important thing i heard in
chris mortensen's report
saying that uh the marriage is basically
irretrievably broken or whatever words
he used
the most important thing is that carson
wentz
is willing to work with an acquiring
team
and the eagles to make the cap situation
a lot less egregious doug marone just
got
fired a couple of minutes ago which is a
big surprise no surprise
but uh they got the number one pick and
no coach
do you think it is urban meyer like is
it his job if he wants it they just have
to go through
the the protocols here i don't report on
this
nearly as well or as thoroughly as guys
like shefter and mord and
ian rappaport and all these guys and
glazer i just
i don't do it anymore dan but i did hear
from a couple of coaches agents over the
weekend
that uh you know they're they are
basically really interested in urban
meyer
and they think that is the way that one
is going to go
and my feeling about it is i would just
approach with caution
you know urban meyer is a guy who left
jobs at
45 46 and 54 either for health reasons
or whatever
reasons and walked away from his teams
and
so and again that doesn't mean anything
but i must say i'm reminded of 15 years
ago when nick staben
signed for five years with wayne
heizenga he was
finally going to get the miami dolphins
back on the shula track
well you know 23 months later he's
sitting in his kitchen with wayne
heisenga saying i'm sorry i want out
and he's 15 and 17 and then he's the
coach of alabama the next day
so again i you know look urban myers
never lost in his life
dan put an underline under that he has
never
lost in his life he's taking oh
he would be taking over a team that
has won 25 percent of its games
over the last three years this is not i
don't care if you draft trevor lawrence
and
and jim brown and barry sanders and
jerry rice
you know you're gonna lose and probably
quite a bit
so i don't know we'll see i think hey
look
they are a fact fine they ought to be
interested i get it
um and maybe they should hire them but i
certainly don't think it's a nirvana
hire
necessarily if they hire them yeah i had
a source last night say ryan day would
be
more attractive to him if
you're the jags because you got a guy
who at least has been in the nfl with i
think the eagles and the niners
and he's a younger guy and the other
thing about ryan day dan
is when mike brabel was
pursuing uh either the indianapolis or
the tennessee job
in 2018 he told the general managers in
both places that
most likely ryan day that's the guy who
i want to be my
uh to be my offensive coordinator
and there was a lot of hesitancy there
you know like
hey get a more established guy like uh
you know like maybe daryl bevel or
or somebody else but uh you know mike
obviously has landed with the absolutely
perfect guy and arthur smith but
i do think that ryan day is is
interesting to a lot of teams in the nfl
the jacksonville job or the jets job
with the ones that are
open um what do you think is more
desirable
well um i think both jobs
would be really interesting to me but
i would have to know several things
especially about
control because the jets history
um is just replete with
changes and failures and and and
you know trying something for two years
and then moving on
i wanna know about how solidly you're
gonna do this i thought it was an
encouraging sign
that joe douglas got a six year contract
so
that job is better than it was before
joe douglas took it
and they've got two ones each of the
next two years
if they choose to trade sam darnold
or choose to trade that pick they could
have
a lot better draft status in 2021 but
i think the jags is a good job too but
it is
all about the people who surround you
talking to peter king his column
football morning in america
is out looking at the playoffs here uh
you know short work week here for jared
goff that surgically repaired thumb
what's the likelihood he'll be
available for the game against seattle
you know all i know
is that uh is what uh mcvay said after
the game last night we don't know
and i don't think it's a disaster if he
doesn't play
because uh honestly
you know if he doesn't play dan uh
he hit he had this had not been a good
year for jared goff
at all um and he had a very poor game a
couple of very poor games down the
stretch
and so i'm not saying that john walford
is better than jared
goff i'm saying that jared goff
has really hit a hit a rut and i would
much rather have jared goff play in the
game
no question about it but i wouldn't like
to have a 68 percent jared goff
play in the game i'd rather just see if
wolford could do it and then see if uh
golf could be ready the following week
if they beat seattle
i wonder what the bears would be doing
today if they didn't make the playoffs
if arizona won
would we be looking at that situation
differently with
the head coach with mitchell trubisky
and the fact they make the playoffs
now what do you do with mitchell
trubisky i think matt maggie is going to
return
and i think he would have returned even
if
the mathematics didn't work out that
they would have made the playoffs i
think ryan pace
that's another story i don't think
they've made that decision yet but i do
think his status
is up in the air as far as trubisky goes
my feeling is that uh that
what the bears probably will end up
doing
is bringing in a young quarterback for
the future of the job and basically
saying to mitchell trubisky
we'd love to have you back at a
reasonable number
and if you can come back at a reasonable
number knowing that
there's going to be competition for the
job that's great
and in my opinion trubisky is going to
find a better opportunity somewhere else
just my guess and a lot can be a lot can
be determined
by what happens in this play playoff
game what if trubisky shocks the world
and the and the bears win the game
in new orleans then i think there's a
very good chance he would stay
but i do think that um he's not coming
back
to a clean job where he's the man
did tom brady live up to the hype the
expectations
well i would say this dan after the game
last night
uh yesterday uh bruce aryan said my goal
for him
was a 40 touchdown 10 interception
season
and he was 40 and 12. and
aryans put an addendum on that he said
to be able to do this
without much practice with no off season
program
uh basically learning on the fly
starting in the middle of august
essentially
is absolutely amazing and i agree with
them
this for tom brady to have one of his
finest ears which
under by any measure second most
touchdown passes he's ever had
and you can say well he's got a great uh
a
a great supporting cast he does but for
him to have been able to do that
is just another uh just another
uh star in his galaxy showing that he's
the greatest quarterback of all time
if i let you uh make your super bowl
pick again do a do-over
uh i don't know i'm like everybody else
i'm really enamored
uh of buffalo i'd pick i'd pick buffalo
in green bay
it would be the all-time rust belt super
bowl and
uh i don't know who i'd pick i'd
probably
pick green bay i just trust rogers so
much right now the way he's playing
and i wonder because kansas city didn't
have anything to play for
if if it factored in on who's going to
win the mvp
with you know roger's still putting up
big numbers whereas
mahomes the last couple of weeks you
know didn't have to
uh and i wonder if if the voters i think
the votes have to be in on wednesday
wednesday yeah yeah if aaron rodgers may
have won the mvp the last two weeks
that's a really good question i think at
the beginning of december
in my opinion josh allen wasn't much of
a factor
you know he played his way into this
he may have passed mahomes right now
and i haven't made my final
determination what i'm going to do
it's either going to be rogers or alan
uh i think it's very close um i'd
probably say rogers
they would have a slight lead with me
but i do dan
every year for these awards i spend
maybe two or three hours
today late in the day just you know
no phone no anything and just really
trying to give this
significant thought i don't want to talk
to anybody i don't want to know anything
i just want to be able to think about it
myself the other one that's really hard
this year
uh is defensive player of the year you
know xavier and howard you could argue
had a better year this year than stefan
gilmore had last year
stefan gilmour beat out uh aaron
aaron donald last year so shouldn't
xavier and howard beat out aaron donald
this year
and that's something i've got to think
about too you got a busy day ahead of
you
no i don't now i got a great nap coming
up then i didn't go to bed till 5 15.
so i'll have a good nap and then i'm
going to get up clear-eyed whatever it
is
and i'll figure everything out thank you
pete we appreciate you getting up and uh
always appreciate the column football
morning in america
peterkingnbcsports.com thank you
we appreciate it all the best dan thank
you